Luca Martin great to see you how far are
things well thank you in a previous
video you showed us how to set up a cscd
pipeline in GitHub actions using service
account keys but you also said there was
a better way of doing it
yeah exporting service account Keys
leads to a lot more work for example
when you need to rotate the keys that's
where workload identity Federation comes
in
but we must use a key right how else
would Google now that the call from
GitHub is legit
the magic is in the implementation
details let's take a closer look
[Music]
alright we're trying to eliminate
exported service account keys but how
can GitHub deploy code securely to
Google Cloud without a service account
key
well if someone had my car key they
could drive my car regardless of whether
I allow it or not yeah that makes sense
Luca and that poses a lot of security
concerns right
exactly and even though GitHub is
securely storing that service account
key it adds one more place of
vulnerability plus the key is
long-lipped right right and many
organizations even forbid the export of
keys for that very reason right
fortunately we now have workload
identity Federation which means we don't
have to rely on Keys anymore
how does that work well with workload
identity Federation when the unknown
actor tries to use my car key in the
analogy earlier I am able to decide if
the car will unlock or not
so instead of my car key being open to
any user out there when the key is
clicked a message is first sent that
describes their identity like who I am
or if I'm old enough to drive for
example exactly when the car key is
clicked a message is sent to a service
that I control I can set it up first to
only trust messages coming from certain
car keys or to only allow users that
meet given condition based on
information in the message itself great
this seems promising look up uh what
happens next so should the authorization
succeed the service will send a token
back to my car key enabling the actor to
use it on behalf of me the token itself
however is only single use got it and
each time the key is used the same flow
takes place sounds like I won't have to
worry about long-lived service account
Keys anymore exactly Martin and we have
some best practices for workload
identity Federation setup as well let's
get into it alright Martin we are going
to start by setting up workload identity
Federation through the cloud UI perfect
and I presume we can always go back and
automate this setup with gcloud commands
at the command line right later exactly
we even have all the commands you need
for setup here in the auth action readme
that's great uh now what's the first
step
the first thing you'll need to get
started is enable the IAM credentials
API in the Google Cloud console
sounds good Luca let me do so real quick
all right should be good to go there uh
what's next awesome so next we're going
to work through configuring a workload
identity pool and provider let's search
for workload identity Federation in the
Google Cloud console sounds good Luca
looks like I'll need to select the new
workload provider and pool option that
is correct there will be a few things
we'll need to do here the first will be
to create an identity pool which manages
a group of identities and their access
to Google Cloud resources thinking back
to our analogy earlier the pool would be
the key ring our car key is on ah okay
that makes sense so the pool just
manages these identities and each of the
identities or keys on the keyring would
be a provider like GitHub for example
exactly Martin in our case GitHub but it
can be entity any identity provider that
supports oidc oh any provider do you
have an example of what you might be
able to do here Beyond GitHub of course
Mark a good example might be a service
running on an AWS ec2 instance accessing
unstructured data from cloud storage
go audit to make sure I'm understanding
then workload identity Federation would
allow my app on Amazon web services to
make a validated request to my Google
Cloud Storage bucket and if valid it
would have short-lived access to that
bucket that is exactly right Martin and
all without the need to export along the
key beautiful it's all falling into
place Luca so to get started let me
create a pool
I'll name this GitHub GitHub actions
Cloud run workflow here to be specific
allow the provider to this pool I assume
that will be GitHub
that's correct let's choose the oidc and
fill in the information for GitHub
perfect filling that now
uh oh what's this is your url field all
about Luca
so that'll be a specific URL where
GitHub issues the oidc token let's check
github's documentation for that
okay uh check-in get github's
documentation
ah there it is found it uh copy that
update that field now
all right uh not what are these
attribute and condition inputs here
great question so the attribute mapping
flag is how we map claims from the oidc
token that GitHub provides two
attributes within Google Cloud got it so
those conditions in the car example that
could be like is the driver 18 or older
are they a family member and so on and
that information would be provided when
the user clicked the car key what sort
of information can GitHub provide here
there's a fair amount that GitHub will
provide you Martin and GitHub has a full
list but to tease out just a few the
repository workflow ID actor and event
name are all common options
so I could for example restrict
authentication based off of the repo
name to further look down access exactly
the only thing we will need to do is map
them to attributes within Google Cloud
let's add a few mappings so the first
mapping will be the required
google.subject which we can set to the
subject for the oidc token all right
adding it now
second we can add a few values one for
the actor in case we want to restrict
access down to the individual person and
the other for the repository okay adding
that as well
now what about the attribute conditions
here uh how do I make sure
authentication is restricted to the
right repository great question and we
do so through the attribute condition
flag the condition can be a common
expression language statement or an IAM
policy I personally like to use Cel it's
really simple to use and great for
evaluating expressions
plus we have great docs on it as well
gotcha what would the common expression
language of Cl statement be in this case
so it's going to be something really
simple let's add a CL statement setting
assertion.repository to the name of your
repo Mart
great doing that now the auth action
provides a lot of flexibility huh it
really does uh okay Luca is this all I
need to do to use workload.nc Federation
with GitHub
the last step Martin would be to allow
the workload identity provider to
impersonate the service account you use
to deploy the cloud run service oh right
and so I need to explicitly specify what
service account will be impersonated so
what service account will this run on on
the Google Cloud side that makes sense
but but how do I do it yeah so once the
pool and provider are created we can
click into the pool and Grant access to
a specific service account
okay I'll click into the pool now so
this service account uh look at this
will be one with access to our Cloud run
resources that's correct
great uh looks like everything is set up
and ready in Google Cloud uh let's go
and update GitHub so let's say all right
I'm in the actions workflow file in
GitHub and I see the original auth
action the one we set up last episode so
what should I change here
so the changes are actually quite simple
instead of the service account key we
are going to add two new parameters the
workflow identity provider and the
service account to impersonate
got it I'm going to fill these in with
GitHub secrets that I will create
shortly so one quick question here okay
what's the format of the workflow
workload identity Federation provider so
the format of the provider includes the
Google Cloud project number the name of
the workload identity pool and the name
of the provider we can also use gcloud
commands to fetch the full provider
programmatically as well
great just fetch the workload identity
provider we really need a shorter name
for it I know that's a lot to say it's a
lot to say all right anyway so so the
this provider and the service account
are saved as secrets in GitHub now
anything else before deploying
nope it all seems set up Martin perfect
let me try out the new say CD workflow
I'll make a minor change to my code here
and let's see if it redeploys my service
let's do it so as the workflow runs
Martin you'll notice that the auth
action step exports temporary
credentials to our environment
awesome and looks like my server is
redeployed to Cloud run and all without
a service account key
it's pretty great right all right Luca
so with these changes anytime my GitHub
action workflow runs the workflow is
validated as coming from my Repository
and a single use key is provisioned for
the cloud run deployment right
exactly Martin we are no longer letting
just about anyone who has access to our
keys use our car that is now Locked Down
based on conditions we control
plus there is no need to export
long-lived credentials which means our
workflow is more secure
brilliant and thank you everyone for
tuning in if you like this video please
subscribe below and leave a comment also
let us know if you have any questions
for Luca about what we covered in this
video and if you're interested in more
actions managed by the Google GitHub
actions team check out their org in the
description below until next time bye
thank you